today I'm doing an experiment that
demonstrates Heisenberg's uncertainty
principle so here I have a green laser
and I'm firing it down towards the front
of the room through a narrow slit now
that slit can be adjusted so it could be
made narrower or wider and the laser
spot is projected onto a screen behind
it so what do you think is going to
happen to this spot on the screen as I
narrow the slit well let's have a look
you see exactly what you'd expect the
spot gets narrower and narrower the
sides are getting cut off by the slit
makes complete sense and if you stop
there
you would never realize that
Heisenberg's uncertainty principle is at
work but if you keep going something
strange happens as you make the slit
even narrower the spot starts to spread
out isn't that incredible you're making
the slit narrower and yet the spot on
the wall is getting wider the narrower
you make it the wider that spot on the
wall becomes to understand this we have
to look at Heisenberg's uncertainty
principle Heisenberg's uncertainty
principle is normally written as Delta X
Delta P is greater than or equal to H on
4pi so what does this mean well it's
about the position and the momentum of a
particle so X is the position of the
particle and P is its momentum so Delta
X is the uncertainty in position and
Delta P is the uncertainty in the
momentum now if you multiply those two
quantities together they must always be
greater than or equal to H on 4pi now H
is Planck's constant and that deserves a
video all to itself like this one by
sixty symbols but for our purposes it's
just a very small number so in our
everyday lives we don't come up against
this uncertainty relation because
everything is much much bigger than H
but as we narrowed the slit we were
decreasing Delta X for those photons so
we were getting more and more precise
about where the photons were passing
through that slit and in a certain point
you come to this limit so that if you
narrow this any further
you're going to break this
to your relationship so what needs to
happen is the uncertainty in momentum
needs to go up I should specify this is
uncertainty in momentum in the X
direction in the horizontal direction so
if before photons were going perfectly
straight now they must veer off to the
left or to the right to ensure that we
don't break Heisenberg's uncertainty
relation and the more you decrease your
uncertainty in position the more narrow
you make that slit the more the
uncertainty in momentum has to go up and
so if these photons are going to the
left and the right that's going to
produce a much wider beam it's really
really non-intuitive but it's the way
the world works
must be the Sun by you drinks with my
mind what about you is really gonna test
you right I don't like tell me the real
answer oh this is for you only
yeah from here with also a huge big
angle CRNAs and October 31 I've got to
say a big thank you to professor Walter
Lewin at MIT he inspired me to make this
video and I also have to say big thanks
to the University of Sydney for letting
me use their equipment and especially to
a Tom and Ralph for helping me set this
all up oh and just one more thing I
should point out that this explanation
of the experiment is slightly
controversial at least in that Henry
from minutephysics and I have been
debating whether it's really that
counterintuitive I mean if you see light
as a wave then all light is doing here
is diffracting that's the phenomenon
where if a wave passes through a slit it
bends at the corners and radiates out in
all directions and that explains the
spreading of the beam but that goes to
the very nature of light is it made of
waves or particles that's something that
I would like to explore in the coming
week so stay tuned for that
but Henry has an excellent video about
Heisenberg's uncertainty principle which
I think makes it more intuitive and less
spooky so if you want to check that out
click on the annotation it's a really
good video
you